thanks to givewell for sponsoring part
of this video 2023 may have been the
most significant year to date in the
history of the climate crisis we saw
huge news in the physical climate system
on land in the atmosphere and
particularly in the oceans and
chological systems but we also saw huge
news in the human system both in the
impacts of a changing climate on humans
but also humans efforts to curtail
further changes to the climate system in
this video let's talk about the biggest
new stories from both worlds though I'd
like to point out that if you'd like to
get this kind of new summary every month
rather than waiting till the end of the
year then you should check out my free
newsletter I summarize the latest news
in climate that month as well as what
I've been up to free to sign up link
will be down in the description let's
start with the biggest news story of the
year which was that 2023 was the warmest
year on record and very likely the
warmest the Earth has ever been while
modern humans have been around the
temperature anomaly this year is likely
to be around 1.4 de C above the
pre-industrial average of course we
can't say for sure just yet because the
year hasn't finished but it seems all
that certain that it's going to be a
significant increase from last year's
temperature anomaly of about 1.2 degre
CI above pre-industrial some months saw
extraordinary increases in temperature
with September's temperature increase
described by the excellent Dr Zeke
housea as absolutely Gob smackingly
bananas North America South America and
Europe all sought notable heat waves and
July this year was made significantly
hotter by climate change for four out of
five human on Earth part of the huge
temperature increase this year can be
attributed to the Pacific Ocean flipping
from a lania states to an elinia state
for more about what that means you can
check out my previous video but this is
directly attributable to us humans and
our emissions of greenhouse gases there
is natural variability in the climate
system but it's on top of a huge warming
signal from our activities 2023 was the
strongest proof of that yet but that 1.4
de C temperature anomaly refers to the
global average average surface
temperature and arguably a bigger news
story this year was the incredible
increase in Ocean heat specifically
ocean heat content has increased
significantly since humans started
burning fossil fuels in the industrial
revolution it's actually been estimated
that up to 90% of the excess heat
trapped in the earth system has been
trapped in the oceans and this year all
kinds of ocean temperature records were
broken the Atlantic was exceptionally
hot the Mediterranean was hot the
Pacific was hot the Antarctic was
perhaps the highest profile headline of
them all with huge decreases in sea ice
coverage going down to Historic lows due
to increasing ocean temperatures of the
continent this led to possibly the
saddest climate news story of the year
in which entire colonies of emperor
penguins lost every single chick this
season because the sea ice underneath
them melted before the chicks developed
waterproof feathers they all drowned
these colonies will almost certainly go
extinct this is what what we're doing to
the planet but while the connection
between Global emissions of greenhouse
gases and increasing in global sea
surface temperature is undeniable at
this point it's also important to state
that there were other factors that led
to increases in ocean temperature this
year specifically changes in shipping
over the North Atlantic reducing sulfate
emissions LEDs to the water there being
warmer than usual as did changes in
atmospheric circulation which reduce the
amount of Airborne dust over the ocean
which would normally reflect sunlight
away and there's also El Nino but even
with those effects the fact remains that
we had ocean heat waves basically
everywhere this year often concurrently
which is worrying quite how worrying we
don't know we'll hopefully find out next
year with further analysis though I do
want to say now that some people have
been posting online this is the
beginning of the end that the headlines
from the atmosphere and from the ocean
this past year indicate the climate has
passed a Tipping Point and we are on the
fast track to Extinction in the next
couple of years and
this is not a position that's supported
by the science unless you believe James
Hansen's paper from this year which most
climate scientists don't headlines this
year made for Grim reading but in my
professional opinion and in the opinion
of every scientist I spoke to this year
the system is in a bad way the climate
is in a bad shape in a way that we
predicted it's not in a bad way in a
shape that indicates things are
completely broken that's an assessment
I'd like to point out that was echoed by
a meta analysis of climate scientists by
the guardian the consensus opinion of
those scientists being 2023 was in line
with predictions so you know maybe take
our warnings about the future a bit more
seriously now because how did climate
change affect humans this year it wasn't
great I've already mentioned the heat
waves and just how many people were
affected by extreme temperatures this
year but there were other impacts too
notably there was a very active Wildfire
season in Europe this year in Libya this
September over 4,000 lives were lost
after storm Daniel brought severe
rainfall that led to catastrophic
flooding storm Daniel formed over the
Mediterranean which was you'll recall
anomalously warm this year and
researchers estimated that the flooding
in Libya was made 50 times more likely
and up to 50% more intense by climate
change of course it should be noted that
this particular disaster was also a
result of human failings in particular
two under maintained dams were
overwhelmed by the rainfall and so
improved maintenance but also improved
warnings and evacuation orders could
have saved lives but this is the pattern
of things to come human systems are
often very fragile and carefully tuned
to specific parameters and if you push
them just a little bit beyond those
parameters slightly more rainall
slightly higher
temperatures they will break the
disaster we saw in Libya this year of
human systems push just a little bit too
far will be repeated time and time again
this Century but we can still limit how
often it's repeated through adaptation
measures and of course bringing down
emissions but Humanity wasn't just
affected by climate change through large
events like heat waves and floods and
wildfires this year scientists reported
that invasive species driven to
migration through climate change among
other factors were costing the global
economy 400 billion doar a year $3.8
trillion of crops and livestock were
lost in the past 30 years due to
disasters many of which were exacerbated
by climate change and researchers also
reported that human health was being
increasingly affected by the climate
crisis and that by not phasing out the
use of fossil fuels an estimated 5
million excess lives were lost every
year due to air pollution and speaking
of not phasing out fossil fuels that
brings us on to cop
28 hit it in a climate conference hosted
in a p state chaired by the head of the
state oil company earned by national
leaders but attended by lots of fossil
fuel lobbyists a final text was agreed
with the perfect outcome for fossil fuel
producers with some progress on the loss
and damage fund agriculture Heating and
roll out of Renewables the real headline
was the first use of language about the
transition away from fossil fuels of
course the phase out of fossil fuels
language was abandoned and the use of
unabated coal power was kept in ensuring
that despite warnings we are rapidly
running out of time to decarbonize the
global economy another year P without
the necessary ambition to do so in fact
the historic agreement further locked
the world into continuing to burn fossil
fuels just now using carbon capture and
storage alongside them a joke of a
solution to the climate crisis but don't
worry it won't disturb the business of
the UAE or all those lobbyists yeah in
case you can't tell I have a very
negative opinion about the outcome of
cop 28 I did a whole video about this
last week go watch that you could argue
I think that this was the year that
carbon capture and storage or CCS really
moved to center stage and with the
historic final text of cop 28 setting
precedent I worry that it's going to be
a key part of cops going forward and
that's only going to prolong the use of
fossil fuels for more information on the
subject I can highly recommend Climer
Adams recent video there'll be a link on
the screen and in the description now at
this point you may be feeling a little
despondent and I can understand why so
the rest of this video is going to be
about progress and there's a lot to talk
about in the world of science this year
we got a better understanding of key
parts of the climate system with a
notable new paper assessing Global
tipping points the big takeaway being we
might hit them sooner than we previously
thought a new analysis of the stability
of the Gulf Stream which warned it might
collapse in the next few decades and was
pretty roundly criticized for its
methods we don't think that's going to
happen and a new analysis of how the
circulation in the ocean near Antarctica
is being disrupted by increasing
meltwater which better constrains our
estimates of when the West Antarctic ice
sheet will collapse as we now think will
happen okay that all came out less
positive than it was in my head if You'
like to stay up to date by the way with
the latest scientific papers in climate
change I can recommend the skeptical
science weekly Roundup newsletter I'll
leave a link to that in the description
as well okay progress a lot of people
don't seem to realize that while we are
not taking sufficient action to limit
warming to 1 and a half degre Celsius
the world is making pretty solid
progress in turning the ship around take
Renewables in the past 3 years humans
added more solar power capacity than in
every year up to 2020 put together and
installations in the next 3 years will
nearly double the International Energy
agency which is normally quite
conservative now describes the shift
towards Renewables as quote Unstoppable
and that based on current policies not
even accounting for increasing ambition
going forwards solar will generate
nearly half the world's electricity by
2030 current policies are working in
America the inflation production Act is
set to significantly reduce emissions in
the EU use of fossil fuels to generate
electricity dropped by 177% in the first
half of this year going down to Historic
lows and China's emissions are set to
Peak this year falling every year going
forwards largely due to the Colossal
roll out of solar power some analysis
indicates that we may have already hit
Peak fossil fuel use for generating
electricity and that Peak fossil fuel
use full stop will occur before the end
of the decade in fact some analysis
indicates that we may Peak Global
emissions as soon as this year which I
personally find quite difficult to
believe 2023 showed us that we are
heading in the right direction progress
is accelerating policy is working it's
still just not working fast enough to
avoid levels of warming that the science
tells us could be dangerous and while
decarbonization of electricity
generation is going well decarbonization
of total energy use including heating
transport industry and other sectors is
slow electrification and low carbon
electricity will help here but we still
have a mountain to climb 2023 was a year
in which we reaped what we seed policy
sewn in the past decade started to
really show its effect and the world
took not insignificant steps towards a
low carbon future but we also reaped the
effects of decades and Decades of
colossal use of fossil fuels temperature
records being broken ocean heat waves
tragic loss of life this year the
climate crisis became more obvious than
ever before this is the decade in which
we must continue to sew effective policy
the phase out of fossil fuels the
decarbonization of not just electricity
but all energy use otherwise we will
continue to reap suffering something
that is now unfortunately inevitable but
we can still limit the amount of hurt
that we experience this century and in
the future I'm going to finish this
video with a few predictions for 2024
but before I do that I want to take this
opportunity to say thank you alongside
all the news in climate this year has
been the most challenging year of my
life between the sudden loss of my dad
to cancer and the birth of my daughter I
have been challenged in ways that I
simply have never been challenged before
and I wouldn't be here making videos if
it wasn't for the support of the people
around me my friends my family
definitely my wife but that also
includes the community of people that
watch my videos if it wasn't for your
support sharing my videos directly
supporting me on patreon I wouldn't be
doing this job anymore I wouldn't be
making this video right now so I want to
take this opportunity to say thank you
for getting me through 2023 but while I
may have had a pretty rough year there
are others out there who are truly in
need of help and this is a time of year
where you may wish to consider
supporting them and donating to charity
doing so is an incredibly personal act
both choosing a cause and a specific
charity but if you would like
information on how to maximize how
effective your donation can be then you
will want to check out givewell who have
kindly sponsored this part of the video
givewell has spent the past 15 years
researching charitable organizations
helping donors make informed decisions
about high impact giving through their
entirely free website givewell has 39
staff researchers who review independent
evidence on how effective each Charity's
work is and make recommendations for
donations to specific Charities over
100,000 donors have used give well to
give over a billion yes with a B dollars
and evidence indicates that those
donations have improved millions of
lives and saved over
150,000 lives if you know anything about
this channel you'll know that I think
high quality data and independent
research should be at the heart of
decision making and so recommending you
to use givewell is incredibly easy and
only made easier by the fact that if you
haven't donated to give well before and
choose to support one of their
recommended Charities before the end of
the year they will match your donation
up to $100 to double the effectiveness
of your donation head to give well.org
go to YouTube and then enter the code
Simon Clark checkout let them know that
you heard about them from me in order to
get your donation matched again that's
givewell dorg to donate or to find out
more with thanks to givewell for doing
fantastic important work and for
supporting this channel okay predictions
for next year firstly while 2023 is the
warmest year on record I think 2024 will
take that title typically El Nino has
the largest effect on global average
temperatures just after it's finished so
I wouldn't be surprised if next year was
warmer than this year they probably
still less than 1 and A2 degrees above
pre-industrial after 2024 we'll probably
see the global average temperature
decrease temporarily secondly cop 29
will be in aaban next year if you don't
know aaban is another Pro State it's
actually one of the places where the oil
industry kind of historically began my
prediction is that carbon capture and
storage is going to be Center St AG in
the negotiations and in particular the
word unabated is going to be applied not
just to Coal but to fossil fuels in
general and that's going to lock CCS
into the discussion at cop 29 and in its
final text and I don't think that's a
good thing third keep an eye on the
waters around Australia this coming
spring if you're in the northern
hemisphere Autumn if you're in the
southern hemisphere it's been forecast
that the Waters of the tasmin sea could
be exceptionally hot this coming spring
and depending on how wide that
temperature anomaly spreads we could be
looking at a colossal Coral bleaching
event fourth staying in the oceans next
year I think we'll see a lot of analysis
of all the ocean heat waves that took
place this year and my prediction is
we'll see a bunch of contradictory
statements I don't think we'll
conclusively get to the bottom of what
happened with all our concurrent heat
waves next year though if those heat
waves continue into next year maybe the
more pessimistic end of the analysis
will be correct and continuing that
point my final prediction is that in
2024 we will see a deepening of the
culture War over climat here in the UK
we've seen a real sharpening of the
battle lines around the climate crisis
with some newspapers spreading some
quite spectacular misinformation I think
this is going to get worse before it
gets better and further I think there's
going to be a real rise in the climate
Doomer movement which is going to
somewhat replace the role as the anchor
to progress that's been so far served by
climate Skeptics I should probably make
a video about that but with that the
year is at an end and so too is this
video thank you so much for watching if
you'd like to help me make more videos
in 2024 then please consider signing up
to my patreon these are the names of my
lovely executive producer patrons who
enjoy early access to my videos vote on
a video topic a month and can watch
exclusive behind the scenes Vlogs every
month if you'd like to join them please
do head to
patreon.com Ox Fizz if you enjoyed the
video please do pop it a like and maybe
share it with people who you think would
also enjoy a summary of all the big
climate news this year as I said
previously thank you so much for your
support this year and I look forward to
seeing you in more videos in
2024 but for now happy holidays thank
you for watching and I'll see you in the
next one